ukrainian president vladimir zelansky
says his country's forces have liberated
8 000 square kilometers in a lightning
counter-offensive in his country's
northeast but as ukrainian troops raised
the flag in towns and villages in the
hakeem region reports are emerging of
the torture and murder of civilians by
russian forces we'll have more on that
in a moment from our correspondent in
the city of
first some of the scenes from the past
24 hours
a mother reunited with her son
he had been fighting in the ukrainian
army for days in the kharkiv region
until his unit liberated his home
village
my son i have been waiting for you
i have kept all your things everything
they said there are mines in the
apartment
mom you're looking good as always i
missed you so much
ukrainian soldiers follow a trail of
destruction as they press their attack
the russians are in a headlong retreat
shedding their equipment as they fall
back
they were running like mice they were
running and abandoning everything
vehicles their own man
they even abandoned one of their own who
was wounded just to get away
the kremlin denies reports that the
military setbacks are turning people
against president vladimir putin
russians support the president and the
mood of the people confirms this
the people stand firmly behind the
decisions made by the head of state
but as ukraine continues to roll back
gains made by russian forces early in
the war
putin's decision to invade ukraine
could come back to haunt him
and we can join dw correspondent
emmanuel shaz in ukraine's second
largest city khaki welcome emanuel um
let us start with these uh reports of uh
torture in the hakiv region what have
you been hearing
well uh phil you might hear behind me
there's a national anthem being played
just as every day at 9 00 a.m ukraine
time in memory of all of the people
civilians and
soldiers alike who fell
during this war they are called the
heroes of
ukraine and it
tells you just how how uh you know
important it is for people to know what
happened
in those occupied territories to give
you an idea after a month of occupation
in bucharest we've seen the horrors
unfolding the war crimes and this is
what we might be looking at in the
places that have been
freed that have been liberated over the
past days it's over 300 settlements
which have been
which have been liberated and from then
start to emerge very very grim reports
of people who have been arrested who
have been tortured
some people
apparently also have been killed there's
a lot of pictures circulating on social
media
of you know corpses being uncovered by
soldiers as they liberate the town so to
give you an idea the general prosecutor
of ukraine already investigates uh over
32
000 cases of war crimes of crimes
against
humanity committed by the russian army
and it seems as if we're looking at more
cases being uncovered every day here in
the harakeev region
and what have people been telling you as
the tide of this war appears to be
turning in ukraine's favor
well what really um
what really came true since i uh i've
been here in ukraine is the resilience
of people here they really have faith in
their army but even then uh i think even
ukrainians were surprised at how
this counter-offensive uh was successful
they expected a counter offensive for
months but they
had no means to evaluate its successes
and it went you know
above and beyond what they could have
hoped uh for example you know uh they
the key cities here in the harkief
region such as uh eastern
such as copeans who are very very
important for the russian army have been
liberated and
in doing so this really hinders
russian
ways of of getting more ammunitions more
material conveyed to those soldiers of
them who are still on the front line and
it seems really that russia russia
really struggles to keep
its defenses on that new front line
and president zielenski said in his
evening address on tuesday that he hopes
for a rapid return to normality in
liberated areas what has that looked
like in places like butcher that have
already been freed from the russian
presence
well uh you know the road to normality
uh will will be long first off because
most of the places uh here have also
been shelled here in the city of harkief
we haven't seen a fighting per se but
there's daily uh shelling like day in
day out and especially
at night
buildings are being shelled so this will
be about uh rebuilding the country this
will take
years of course but people here are very
much ready to do so
thank you for that emmanuel shaz in
hakim
german chancellor olaf schultz has
repeated his call for vladimir putin to
withdraw his troops from ukraine and a
phone call with the russian president
chancellor schultz urged him to find a
diplomatic solution based on a ceasefire
as a offensive by keeves forces made
speedy progress a german government
spokesperson said mr schultz also urged
mr putin to respect ukraine's
sovereignty and territorial integrity
dw political correspondent hans brandt
can tell us more welcome hans what sort
of diplomatic solution is germany
calling for what would that look like
well there's those first three steps
that were just mentioned the
ceasefire would be the first step the
second step that has been demanded is
that russia withdraw its truth from
ukrainian territory the third step would
be for russia simply to respect
ukrainian territorial integrity
but in fact all of these are just
preconditions for diplomatic solutions
for diplomatic
negotiations um
the the exact framework or the exact uh
look of such a solution is not really
clear at the moment
even the german government has not
really been given any details about what
it might think about in ukraine at the
same time there have been discussions
with western allies about what kind of
security guarantees ukraine might need
after the war um
equipping the ukrainian army military
support and support from western uh
countries this in fact has then uh
called for a very severe reaction from
dmitry medieva for the former prime
minister and president of russia who
said that would be tantamount to ukraine
joining nato so we're very far away from
a diplomatic solution at the moment okay
and so
let's look at what
germany has been doing because key has
been consistent in its demands for
western support send us more weapons
particularly tanks but this seems to be
a line the german chancellor is
reluctant to cross and this appears to
be causing friction within his
government
yes indeed the the major dispute is
around tanks and armored personnel
carriers these are demanded by kiev
german tanks leopard tanks
and they they are basically available
but the german government has been
saying repeatedly in the last couple of
days that is not going to go alone in
making such a decision
the defense minister said recently that
no western country has so far supplied
western technology tanks to ukraine and
germany would not be the first to do
that but within the german government
there are voices that are saying that
with the initiative on the side of
ukraine at the moment on the battlefield
this should be taken
as
the time to supply tanks so that ukraine
can make further advances in this battle
against the russian invasion okay thank
you hans dw political correspondent hans
brandt